for all we know all this could be on the
media and put out there just to make it
seem like the cops are races right
because I don't believe any of I think
it's people that a race is not a sister
I can't generalize people that everyone
wants the same and it's time for the
latest change my mind in the previous
installment we had an interaction with
the man who began yelling racist over
our conversation predictable victim got
a predictable victim if you missed that
video click the card above or the link
in the description to watch but let's
compare that interaction with the one
that I experienced with this strapping
young lad Zack I like the Duke knock let
me ask you this before we start anything
else that's a very tight feel like the
fade now this is one thing I will say in
bridging the cult white people get their
hair cut like like maybe five six weeks
but I you can't make a haircut like that
work unless you do it how often get to
do it so I get every other Friday my dad
okay the next Friday after the next you
know 6:30 always scheduled my dad likes
to keep everything scheduled I usually
meet a man yeah well I mean he's
ex-military now but I get the bald fade
that way when it grows back at least is
still which faded throughout and then
I'm just trying to grow it hotter okay
yeah cuz you know I get sometimes people
call the the jew-fro
but I get it it grows out yeah you can
see a little bit of a wave this is after
putting a hat on it to mat it down
because it grows out of curls yeah so I
mean I look like one of those like you
know those little old-time kids with the
curls looking a lollipop and that's
exactly why his ass because it's very
nice none of you at last Friday
oh sorry do you mind no problem go ahead
here I'll take away my microphone okay
all right so it sounded like you might
be familiar with the change my mind a
little bit
yeah first what it is you know it's not
really debated rationalizing a position
today we did talk about kovat
but right now we were talking
because of the riots right now and
because of all this going on and demands
that are being laid out in the public
and black lives matter and the public
eye I do not believe that today in 2020
the United States is a racist country
certainly not systemically and if you
disagree I'm more than willing to have
you change camera no I mean I agree with
you I mean I feel like racism really
comes down to people's ignorance I'm not
really understanding or knowing someone
else to different culture and I mean
most people I've met in Texas like I've
seen more racist people while you live
in Northeast no I did in New York yeah
so many races like you'd see cab drivers
anyway like I don't know like if you're
still like close with Jill wrote him
like I've seen something like but not
like fight for like a man black guys
no no just like I was something that he
says like honest conflict is better than
dishonest harmony and I think people are
just gonna be people that I'd rather you
be authentic with yourself you don't
like me because of my race just want me
to be truthful don't why because like
some people we know like be nice and
then truly get to know them you know
yeah
yeah I mean I think too like we were
talking with the harrassing and I was
talking with a man name was Kendall
who's a young black man and he said that
he felt like there were these three
conceived notions these expectations of
what it is to be a black man you said me
and that that was hard to live up to and
he said that you know we're all athletic
and he said you know he wasn't really
that way he was kind of seemed more like
a book smart kind of guy and I think
that's a good example of something where
I don't think that I have that as a
white person and so we don't need to be
colorblind I mean well that sounds
pretty hard people expect you to act a
certain way because you're black and we
said yeah and you don't know that that's
okay like to tolerate over so hey that
kind of thing
it was very nice articulate man and so I
think there are differences and learning
about that
is a good it means like I can be
ignorant for example like you get your
hair cut I don't know any white guy gets
his hair cut every other week Dini I
just learned something yeah I mean I
think I think we should take pride in
getting so you know have having that
experience to be able to learn from
others I feel like a person should
always want to be you know likes me in
their mind and like there's nothing
wrong with that you wanted to know for
yourself not because you were trying to
be condescending or demeaning in any way
right dad was a former military man he
so a strict guy yeah what is his view
right now in the riots and the black
lives matter and the law enforcement we
do not speak that much like about this
issue my brother he he protests he
doesn't believe in the rioting and
looting I don't think any of our family
members do but uh I don't think America
systemically racist well it's like if
you do were look at like the amount of
black men per 1000 and white men per
1000 because I believe the Caucasian
race in three times triples of the black
people correct or is that black that
Ronnie and the number two make up
between 10 and 50 percent of the United
States population but still at the same
amount of blacks being killed his whites
even though there are more white people
two black people that's not talked about
quite and actually it's significantly
less but you can't just base it on
percentages so yeah I don't want to be
another myself you know right but even
more there are numbers I think that are
more relevant in that scenario so for
example last year there were nine
unarmed black man shot by police office
okay
[Music]
white guys there were 19 mm-hmm
now if you look at those numbers and
just say well that's not nearly as much
more as there are white people in the
country we also have to take into
account interactions with officers based
on violent crime and I'm sure this isn't
a surprise necessarily to you but the
number was do you know how much more
likely a black male specifically a black
male
is to commit homicide in a white male
over 35 times 50% of all homicides in
the country are committed by live
doesn't a lot of that is gang violence
you know that happens in neighborhoods
and they don't have that so much even in
poor white favorites and only have the
same gang on gang violence so it's not
necessarily just you know black on white
crime or white on black crime and they
also commit 60% of what I mean if we're
all we know it's like I think there's
always like secret of secrets and
there's always a generous like for all
we know all this could be on the media
and put out there just to make it seem
like the cops are racist right because I
don't believe any of I think it's people
that a race is not a sister I can't
generalize people that everyone wants
the same and I think and I think yes and
I think that we need to reform to come
from that place of understanding for
example police are former defund the
police know here is my proposed solution
though at least some steps that I hope
we could find some common ground at
least strip some of the power away from
police unions and protect bad police
officers and I think we need better
training for police officers
specifically an unarmed combat so for
example right now you go in you do a
couple of physical things and you don't
necessarily have to stay up on your
tests and so think about you get into a
violent conflict with a man your only
option is to go to your tool belt yes
like I can't fight yeah my dad was
speaking about it like a lot of
ex-military come cops you're trying to
kill in the military not to suppress you
know protecting serve I feel like this
is somewhat longer on this muddled you
know I don't think that necessarily
protecting themselves before they're
protecting citizens right but in some
cases they are yeah you know and
something like I said I will not try to
generalize idly no best interests you
know yeah like do you see the Atlanta
shooting you saw it what happened to me
and did you see the full tape it's like
about the guy he officers two of them
yeah fight one off so here's a good
question because he spiked one officer
on his head right now the officer
reached if I meant he grabbed his wrist
yeah that's something if everybody
already shake ass if anyone if anyone
has ever done a month in jiu-jitsu or
dude or some kind of grappling art right
away they would learn how to control
that you would learn
month and most cops doing their hair
like Jeff about this yeah so like okay
the training I feel like just like I saw
videos like it takes more time to become
a barber than it does to become an
officer with a gun
ya know I just think they should be
taught to lower you know lethal force if
they're here to protect us don't know
right now don't kill us you know like
just like even if it hurts us like to
detain us I mean we are you know our
biggest enemy I believe I think I think
everybody especially when you have a rap
did you know about the rap sheet from
Rashard Brooks no see that's something
note so you know you probably look for
the full tape and this is this is
something I'm curious about as it wasn't
I'm asking you because you weren't a
black man because that went out and
opera we're saying it's another public
execution in the lynching CNN and I've
watched them for hours and hours and
hours every day
have you never run the full table
they've only run the long shot grainy
footage where you shot they've never run
the full tape this guy didn't just have
a rap sheet this guy committed theft the
sky abstract this guy committed cruelty
to children and false imprisonment and
II it had multiple in other words this
was a guy who was going to go away for
likely a long time on these arrests so
was presented as though he was drunk he
pulled into a parking space in Wendy's
right to try and sleep it off no this is
a guy who likely wasn't just drunk but
he was so inebriated he fell asleep in
the drive-thru line failed a sobriety
test and when they tried to simply
handcuff him beet dish
he'd the hell out of jail mister he
stole a gun as possible for the I'll do
it and they didn't even shoot him he was
the only shot him when he turned back
and aimed their taser at him he mean I
understand that's a non-lethal weapon
the why do cops have it to incapacitate
so if you're incapacitated Coble his
taser now all congratulations you just
won the deadly weapon lottery you know
and so to me when I watched that my was
even bad after watching it really I mean
I wish didn't happen but I don't think
I'm taking like a life was taken right I
don't agree with that sure I mean I feel
like I have Christian principles myself
and uh I don't believe in taking your
life what I mean
at that point in the in the world that
we live and you had to be asking for
that rail because people get shot for
much less right why people get shot for
much yeah I mean that's I put this way
is it unfortunate sure do I think that
officer had any malice no and I
certainly don't see any evidence right
now but he did that because he wasn't
racist yeah and I mean I've been around
people you know white people that are
nicer and more friendly to me than black
people right yeah and it even as school
people say why do you talk or act or
dress of white I'm like what's always
speaking with articulation and somewhat
intellect why be stupid and you know
appeal to the masses that was something
that the that Kendall brought up to I
want to ask is that something that you
feel is expected of you to speak and act
a certain way from I feel like it's more
of what people want people want you to
put on a show every day
I mean if I spoke like that they
wouldn't take me seriously but you know
they get a good laugh out of it like I
said hey oh what's up man how you doing
blood you know it's like like what do
you get out of that like why speaking of
slang when you know what I mean like
when I'm speaking now the English
lexicon yeah right yeah well I don't
know I know cuz that's what he was
talking about their expectations of
black men yeah then I mean there's all
these roles like this gender roles raced
roles like yeah it goes on like if
you're Asian you're supposed to be
smaller or something you know I mean
yeah I don't know I hope that's the case
because my lawyer is that's why I hired
him it was either now you couldn't
afford it you yeah but uh I'm on a time
restraint but one last thing so yes I'm
only 17 right and like you're a tall
seventeen right good for you right I've
no I'm not really that deep into
politics and like I hate when people ask
me but because like I feel so ignorant I
don't want to speak wrongly so it's like
how do you really get into politics so
you know what you're speaking about
because like what source do you go to
you yeah um well let me first off I need
to get your info because we'll probably
need permission since you're underage -
yeah but it should all come I didn't
realize I first you're here by consensus
okay that'll be good enough and then if
not just me as long as your dad is cool
we all be conscious being I know but I'm
not really I came into it as a standard
this is a comedian and I was at Fox News
for years I will say this and hopefully
there'll be some developments that make
this easier for people in the future
like you know if you look at we always
have these sources so that people can
reference them but I tell you what I do
just this is just my advice it could be
wrong assume that there is no unbiased
hate you so assume that you're getting
some kind of a spin left or right and so
start off with that one I do is I set
bookmarks and if I read if I read Fox
News right away I read HuffPo and then
if I read something like daily called
right away I read sleep and I just make
sure that I stack my deck right left
right left so that I can see the same
story covered from different angles in
me and then I'll go and look up the
original sources and try and find the
data that's actually accurate and
unbiased but I think a big mistake
people do and they didn't see CNN for a
long time let's go
well MSNBC is left side my left your
right and Fox News is right so CNN's
down the middle now CNN is really far
left and I think that most news sources
are biased chosen either way create a
Venn diagram yeah one side the other
side to find the commonality yeah I
would say start by setting three
bookmarks both left and right in and
check those and even like you can set
the for example Reddit politics might as
well be the Communist Manifesto and then
find if there is a reddit considered we
want to know about the past they're like
oh hey sorry yeah well people ask me
like I support Trump last important cuz
my dad does and I believe he does some
good for the country mm-hmm I don't hate
on the guy don't hate anyone like like I
was saying like I have Christian
principles yeah and everyone's gonna
have another religion of belief anyway
that's the only we were gonna solve this
shared principles yeah and a heart for
each other I mean I don't believe in God
I mean even the Bible study I like to
live by even right yeah kill right yeah
so um I feel like people say a lot of
bad things about Trump and I'm like you
know I'm gonna stance I don't know what
to say cuz I don't know what's true or
false about the guy
yeah his past in the presidency because
I wasn't keeping up with the back then
yeah I would still say the same applies
where try and find some even if it's
just books or articles that interest you
so for example you could right now
probably search New York Times Donald
Trump history and you'll find some stuff
yeah and then you could search and if
you go read Trump's book himself because
you'll be all too happy to give you his
history take that with a grain of salt
Sam
the same thing applies because even with
teachers everyone is often trying to
give you their point of view and listen
that's what this is I know they have a
point of view that's why it says change
my mind it doesn't say oh I don't know
let's talk like I try to be
straightforward about the fact that I do
have a point of view a lot my problem
isn't with people who have a different
point of view
I promise with people who claim to be
unbiased and lie about it so all I can
say is whether it's reading history
whether it's reading current events
assume that whoever is compiling or
writing it has some kind of biases just
like the black lives matter movement so
they say said unconscious biases well
how do you fix something it was not even
conscious but assume that everyone has
that and just trying to balance it out
and I know it's hard but you just have
to bite off a piece at a time
you know so maybe it's gonna take time
it's gonna take you're 17 you're plenty
of time and also like something that
will change my mind about school black
lives matter like at first like when I
saw it I was like don't always matter
right I think yeah when you stepped into
that one yeah right
how'd you get some people don't know I'm
black myself I can say but uh I I read
more into it's not that all lives don't
matter I think the movement was more so
as you see on the media right as what
people see the masses black lives being
taken by the system yeah I think they're
saying all lives matter but black lives
need it more yeah I feel like why not
just try to make everybody on the same
level first well listen when you when
you have a movement that's demanding
that people kneel solely because of
their race I don't think it's looking
for equality yeah you know Nate I mean
there was there was a time in this
country where black people had to kneel
unfortunately and that was slavery that
we ended and I think is a great evil and
as Christians were called to kneel
before no man there's still in Africa by
the way the pygmies have two was a Bantu
tribes if to kneel to other tribes six
million people are slaves in Africa not
to mention across Asia the whole reason
that the American flag we have this we
stand for the Pledge of Allegiance is
because it's a country that requires us
to kneel for no man and so I think
people said well kneeling is so symbolic
I agree
moment you ask someone to kneel over
their whiteness it's just as evil as
asking someone to kneel over their
blackness and its ultimate it's not
about equality and this is the kind of
conversation this is what I think is
productive like you said the only ones
gonna heal us is shared values and in
the United States those shared values
that say you don't kneeled anybody those
are Christian fundamentalist values as
the media would call it me I just think
it's the Americanism yeah that's good
morals good ethical very well Zak was
your name yes hey Thank You Man
appreciate it that was nice but what are
your thoughts on America as a racist
nation of course comment in the comment
section below
keep it civil I know lots of you won't
and if you want to keep this series
alive please do consider joining us but
a lot of credit calm / mug Club you get
hours of content every day that is not
available on YouTube as well as access
to the entire blaze catalog otherwise we
will see you here on YouTube every day